we are making a watch list and checking
it twice this Christmas there are plenty
of new holiday movies you have to catch
from sequels to Classics new musicals
and even Christmas horror movies with
cult Killers yeah this is going to be
one fun Christmas if you watch the right
movies that is start your holiday movie
marathon with a trip down candye Lane
Candy Cane Lane Stars none other than
Eddie Murphy as Chris a Christmas fici a
Who will stop at nothing to win his
neighborhood Christmas decorating
contest this year so he does what any
true Christmas lover would do he makes a
deal with an elf played by Jillian Bell
and let's just say it doesn't go exactly
as planned honestly it's like you're
signing your life away away the film
which also Stars Tracy Ellis Ross Nick
Offerman Robin the and more will start
streaming on Amazon Prime video on
December 1st now if you prefer your
Christmas movie's action-packed then red
one may be your new movie of choice this
year many of the details of what we can
expect in this film have been kept Under
Wraps we do know however that it will
have quite the allstar cast led by stars
Dwayne The Rock Johnson and Chris Evans
the action comedy will also star JK
Simmons and Bonnie Hunt as Santa and Mrs
claw and they'll be joined by plenty of
other big names including lucilo Kieran
shipka Nick croll Mary Elizabeth Ellis
Wesley Kimmel and Christopher hiu while
the folks behind this movie clearly have
some reason for staying tight LIF about
what Will Go On In this action comedy
story developer and producer hyram
Garcia did call it an epic Edge ofyour
seat action adventure that takes beloved
holiday mythology and turns it on its
head so a release date is still in the
works but it's set to stream on Amazon
Prime video this year dashing through
the snow will give us another fun and
and Goofy take on the classic Christmas
comedy with a plot reminiscent of the
Tim Allen classic the Santa Claus
dashing through the snow follows Eddie
who's played by ludicrous claustrophobic
fear of Santa Claus that's ludicrous
Eddie is a social worker at the Atlanta
Police Department whose childhood trauma
has left him relating a little too hard
to the Grinch when the holiday season
rolls around chrm dad isn't that nice
sound like wounded Ducks Eddie has to
take his daughter along with him on a
call on Christmas Eve and in a
roundabout and very magical way he ends
up finding the Christmas spirit what you
about to witness is a Sligh being pull
by eight beautiful
Reindeer the holdovers brings us a very
very different style of holiday comedy
and this one has a lot of heart said in
the 70s a teacher named Paul ham played
by Paul gamti I can tell by your faces
that many of you are shocked at the
outcome stays at the boarding school
where he works over the holiday break to
supervise the students who have nowhere
to go Paul bonds with the head cook all
we've got is whatever is in that walk-in
played by Divine Joy Randolph and the
only remaining student 15-year-old Angus
played by Dominic cesa go ahead tell me
something about me something negative
despite their lonely circumstances
during the holidays the trio enjoys the
festive season with each other the movie
hit theaters on November 10th and has
already raked in some Award
nominations if you prefer Christmas with
a side of Revenge rather than reindeer
then your pick of the Season should be
silent night an action flick that
follows godlock father played by Joel
kinaman whose son was killed and gang
Crossfire on Christmas Eve he loses his
voice after sustaining his own injuries
and now he's committed to getting
revenge for his son at any cost Silent
Night is set to hit theaters on December
1st while some folks enjoy the idea of a
vengeful holiday season others simply
prefer the best Christmas ever if that
sounds more your speed then you'll want
to check out best Christmas ever this
romcom Stars Brandy Norwood as Jackie a
woman with a picture perfect life that
she shows off every year in her
Christmas newsletter dear friends family
and fellow Earth dwellers life just
seems to fly by when you're having a
splendiferous time her ex-friend from
college Charlotte played by Heather
Graham brings her family along to drop
in on Jackie and disprove the perfect
life she boasts about in her newsletter
something is off here nobody's life is
that wonderful despite the major flaws
within Charlotte's plan the holiday
season manages to bring these two former
friends back together this Netflix
original starts streaming on November
16th from the best Christmas ever to the
first Christmas ever journey to
Bethlehem is a holiday tale ripped
straight from the Bible but this time
it's a musical journey to Bethlehem
follows the classic tale of Mary played
by Fiona Palomo Joseph played by Milo
Manheim and the birth of Jesus Antonio
Bendera also joins the cast as Herod for
a surprising retelling featuring comedy
and an original pop soundtrack you can
see journey to Bethlehem in theaters as
of November 10th now for another very
different retelling of a classic story
this holiday season there's Genie Genie
is a remake of the 1991 TV movie Bernard
and the genie both the original and the
new remake were written by Richard
Curtis who wrote another classic
Christmas movie Love Actually in Genie
Bernard played by Papa ESU is visited by
a genie named Laura played by Melissa
McCarthy who are you I am a genie yeah
okay yeah your wish is my command Flora
promises to give Bernard his wish to win
back his family's Love by Christmas and
he teaches her a few things along the
way tell me about this whole Christmas
thing of yours it was meant to celebrate
the birth of Jesus Christ Jesus are you
talking about Mary's kid you actually
met him what did he do to get so famous
Genie hits peacock on November
22nd if like so many you're a fan of the
Diary of a Wimpy Kid franchise then
Diary of a Wimpy Kid Christmas Cabin
Fever is a perfect Christmas present for
you the famous titular Wimpy Kid Greg
hefley who's voiced by Wesley Kimmel as
always has a very chaotic holiday season
full of things going wrong Greg gets
snowed in with his family breaks a
snowplow in a snowman building accident
and he has worries about what he'll get
for Christmas Diary of a Wimpy Kid
Christmas Cabin Fever will be streaming
only on Disney Plus on December 8th for
another fun part of another fun animated
franchise there's a sequel to the bad
guys the bad guys a very bad holiday is
a Netflix short that follows Mr Wolf and
his Pals as they unite to bring the
city's holiday spirit back just in time
for the season wel good guys this is it
the Special will hit Netflix on November
25th and it's only 25 minutes long so
it's perfect for the kids to watch over
and over again now if animated movies
aren't your thing and you're more of a
fan of something that definitely isn't
holiday fun for the whole family then
you may want a dose of horror set during
Christmas time the Sacrifice game is set
in the' 70s and follow students stuck at
an all girls school over the holiday
season Samantha played by Madison Baines
and Clara played by Georgia Akin are
forced to spend their Christmas fighting
off a cult of killers now if this is
your style of holiday movie then you'll
be excited to hear that this one has a
100% on Rotten Tomatoes it starts
streaming on shudder on December 8 so
which new Christmas movie are you most
excited to see how' you manage that oh I
don't know are there any others on your
holiday watch list that we missed let's
discuss it in the comments you you know
what the elves the elves took it on the
road and for more videos like this one
like And subscribe to the
things